foreign
[Music]
ER and I'm an assistant professor at the
Washington University School of Medicine
today I'm going to be talking about the
application of long read sequencing in
human genetics
in my lab we're very interested in using
genomics to solve both rare and common
disease and in particular we currently
focus on autism and other
neurodevelopmental disorders 90 minus
syndrome and undiagnosed disease here
I'm showing you a typical genomic work
flow going from the patient presentation
all the way to variance in
interpretation I want to point you to a
specific part of this workflow though
and that is the sequencing step
So currently the state of the art for
large-scale assessment of many genomes
is to do short read sequencing on a
sequencer like the one shown here and in
my previous work and also in present
work I focused on sequencing tens of
thousands of individuals and looking at
that data
now we are kind of moving into a new era
in human genetics and it's a very
exciting time
and it's brought about by this new
technology called long read sequencing
and in my lab we've had the opportunity
now to look at 78 individuals using this
technology and that's the main focus of
my talk today
[Music]
so here's the overall outline for my
talk
first I want to talk to you about
genomic variation and Technology
as you may be aware there are many types
of variation present in the genome it
can be small variation like single
nucleotide variants so those are single
nucleotide changes can be small
variation in small insertions or small
deletions
can be multi-nucleotide variant changes
and there can be Str expansions as shown
on the top right
we also have medium to large variation
including things like duplications
deletions inversions and translocations
where a piece of another chromosome can
move to a different chromosome as shown
in the bottom right
now over the years many genomic
technologies have come online and each
of them is really good at doing certain
things and so I'm showing you here a
table that kind of summarizes what these
Technologies can do and what I hope you
can appreciate is that on the far right
long read whole genome sequencing is
able to do many of the different
detections for these variant classes
I want to make a point here that
throughout the remainder of my talk when
I refer to Long read sequencing I'm
referring to Pac bio HiFi longweed
sequencing with high accuracy and
approximately 20 kilobase pair reads
so if we look at this table for a few
for a few seconds here what you can see
is that things like single nucleotide
variants small insertions small
deletions they're not detectable in
karyotypes they are detectable on snip
microarrays and in whole exome
sequencing data in certain locations and
also in short read whole genome
sequencing data in regions where we have
high map ability
now we can detect these variant classes
in longweed whole genome sequencing data
as well
multi-nucleotide variants are somewhat
similar Str expansions are really well
detected in longweed data but there's
been a lot of bioinformatic work to
really improve this in short read whole
genome data
so the bottom half of the table focuses
on structural variance and copy number
variants and you can see that until
recently with the long read sequencing
it's been very hard to detect that kind
of intermediate size
structural variation so between 50 base
pairs and a thousand base pairs
and moving along or along the rest of
the table you can see that some of the
bigger events have been detectable in
other Technologies but also are
detectable in this new long read data so
now that I have given you hopefully a
sufficient background I want to move
into long read sequencing itself so we
received our first long read sequencing
genome in December of 2020 so about five
months ago and as soon as we got that
data the first thing that we worked on
was an analytical workflow
and this is the analytical workflow that
we currently use and have developed in
the last few months importantly I want
to focus at the top on the utilization
of Base both case and Control Data and
starting the raw pack bio sequencing
data files we find this to be very
critical and I'll talk a little bit more
about the controls in just a moment
if we look at the left side of this
diagram though we can see that there is
an assembly-based approach aspect of
this workflow on the right side we see
there's a reference based approach so
the reference based approach is actually
very similar to what we've done
previously with short read sequencing
data just some of the tools are a little
different but they're the same idea
so on the reference base side we used a
mapper called pbmm2 to align our reads
to a reference genome we use most depth
to build read depth profiles and pbsv to
call structural variants we've built a
custom workflow that can integrate these
two data sets into a combined copy
number and structural variant data for
each individual and then we can combine
that data using Survivor to get a final
joint call set of all samples
on the far right you'll see what we use
for single nucleotide variants and small
insertions and deletions so we first
call these with deep variant we then
phase them with WhatsApp and then we
take all of the samples all this
information and we joint genotype with
the GL Nexus joint genotyper to get a
final combined data set
so all in all we have a very
comprehensive workflow that can detect
many forms of variation if not all and
it's been a pretty um fun time I do want
to note though that there's a lot of
future development I mean we're working
on some things and others as well so I
think this is only the beginning and
it's a very exciting time
the first piece of data that I wanted to
show you was actually for single
nucleotide variants in indels because it
was quite surprising to me because newer
pack bio Hi-Fi data is highly accurate
and this is pretty amazing so here I'm
showing data from an individual who was
sequenced by Illumina and the same
individual sequenced by Pac bio hi-fi
and run through the Deep variant
workflow so it's the exact same kind of
analysis but just different data inputs
what I hope you can appreciate on the
left hand side of the slide is it
generally the distribution of different
variant types is the same
in the middle you can see the ti TV
ratio is good for both
on the right I think this really shows
the main benefit
um in this size range for Pac bio and
that is that Beyond being able to do
single nucleotide variants we can now
start to look at indels in a better way
so on the top you can see that with the
short read data we can find indels
between about a 50 base pair deletion to
about a 40 base per pair insertion
if you look along the bottom though with
pack bio we can reliably get insertions
out to about 500 base pairs so this was
really cool and the first individual
that we sequenced and looked at we saw
there was this novel variation
so there's a repeat expansion detected
in this individual and that's shown with
a little box on the bottom right of this
t-view plot
this individual has autism and this
repeat expansion happens in the five
Prime utr of the fmr1 gene Now by a
pathogenicity scoring software this was
indicated as an important variant and it
was not present in control variant
databases
so we were quite excited however being a
human geneticist I was a bit skeptical
because that variation does not look
like what you would normally see for an
expansion in someone with fragile X
syndrome for for example it looks too
short
so that led me to the next area which is
looking at public data sets to generate
frequency assessments
now as I mentioned no public data had
seen this variant and so what we did was
we looked all over on the web trying to
find public pack bio Hi-Fi data and we
identified 49 PEX bio HiFi genomes from
a project called the pan Genome Project
and we accessed this raw data in January
2021 and we processed all of the
individuals from the raw data through
our bioinformatic workflow that I showed
you a few slides ago
when we did this to our great surprise
and somewhat to our release this
variation has an allele frequency of
27.6 percent in these pan genome
individuals which indicates that it's
probably not relevant for our patient
but it told us that having Control Data
was very important for the type of work
that we're doing when we're looking at
patients
the other cool part about the pan genome
data is that you can do things that
actually I wasn't quite sure we would be
able to do with Pac bio Hi-Fi data we
can actually because it is so accurate
we can do the types of things we used to
do with Illumina data and pretty much we
still do with Illumina data but one
thing that we can do is what I'm showing
here is a principal component analysis
and this shows individuals from
different populations in pan genome and
also shows individuals we have assessed
in my lab so if I break this out so you
can see it better
what we find is that the PCA actually
splits people out by ancestry pretty
much the way we would expect and so on
the left hand side you can see different
populations in Africa moving to the
middle you can see that there are people
from Puerto Rico and then moving to the
right you can see individuals who are
from the Americas and East Asia South
Asia and Europe and as you can probably
notice on the right hand side ours are
labeled in little squares with x's and
those are our patients and you can see
that many of them cluster near the
individual of European ancestry although
we do have one near Columbia and we have
one near the Han Chinese South
so this was incredible to me that we can
actually do this and I think it also
highlights the diversity in the public
data being really useful as a control
for these types of analyzes and I hope
that additional samples will come online
in the near future
the next thing that I'm going to discuss
is phasing of variant data
so to face genomic variation we are just
looking to see which chromosome the
variant resides on and I've shown a very
simple schematic on the right where we
are showing two chromosomes and you can
see at the top position there is an A on
the chromosome on the left and there is
a g on the chromosome on the right and
then at the next position right below
that we have a g on the chromosome on
the left and we have a t on the
chromosome on the right
now actually doing this from short read
data is challenging
and we often have to think of kind of
innovative methods to to get to this
but this is really important when you're
looking at compound heterozygotes in
autosomal recessive genes now
um I've mostly study autism throughout
my career and so I was really interested
in looking at all those autism genes and
the phasing over those look really nice
but I thought that for today I would
show you an example of a gene where
autosomal recessive is kind of what
causes the disease and the example I'm
using is phenol ketoneuria and I'm
looking at data from one of our patients
over the pah Gene
so the first thing that I want you to
appreciate from this is that the window
I'm showing you here is 126 kilobase
pairs in size so this is a very large
region
the next row below that is actually the
top row in this diagram is the coverage
that we got from Pac bio Hi-Fi so this
is about a 20x genome
right below that are the reads that were
faced to haplotype one and for phasing
as I remind you we use WhatsApp
right below haplotype 1 are the reads
that were faced to haplotype two
and then directly below that is the
phase block so you can see this phase
block is really big and it goes across
the whole Gene and actually it extends
further beyond the gene so it's a very
large block but I'm just focusing on the
gene here
then immediately below that I'm showing
you the Illumina phase block so this is
the short read data
again I process this through the same
analytical workflow using deep variant
and WhatsApp to do the phasing trying to
keep things as consistent as possible
this is really amazing and if you're
thinking about uh you know autosomal
recessive and you were really interested
in perhaps compound hats in this Gene
then knowing that the variant that I've
highlighted on the top is on haplotype 1
and the variant that I've highlighted on
the bottom is in haplotype 2 would be
very important if those are the you know
Gene breaking events for example
now I'm going to show you some
information where we looked at the um
sort of the statistics about this and I
do apologize these were colored I think
they've been converted to black and
white here but um basically hopefully
you get the sense of it on the left hand
side when I'm showing are the percent of
phased variants and what I hope you
appreciate is that of the variants that
you could potentially face with Pac bio
you can phase almost all of them
purchase incredible
um with alumina that's lower
and then likewise on the right hand side
what you can see is there are about 43
times more phase blocks detected in
short read sequencing data than in Long
read sequencing data and so if we just
go back to the last slide for one moment
you can see there are many more Illumina
phase blocks here right but actually
having just one big phase Block in the
pack bio is more beneficial
and the reason why there are less blocks
is because the blocks are bigger and now
I'm showing you on the left hand side
the average block length in base pairs
so on average the blocks impact biodata
is about 186 kilobase pairs as opposed
to about 31 kilobase pairs in alumina
on the right hand side if we look at the
actual number of variants we can see
there are about 60 times more variants
in a pack bio block phase block then in
the short read data so this is an
incredibly important advance for the
field of human genetics to be able to do
this kind of assessment right away just
from the read data is amazing
okay now the next part I'm going to talk
is about the assembly-based approaches
because let's face it if you have long
read sequencing data one of the coolest
things about it is that you can do de
novo assemblies
so we wanted to look at this more
formally
what I mean by a de novo assembly just
in case you're not aware what it is it's
basically building a genome from the
read information only
we don't need a reference genome all we
need are the reads from this individual
now generally from the data that we have
we can see there is a linear
relationship between the coverage that
you have and the number of smart cells
that you sequence the individual on
so generally speaking you can see that a
two smart cell genome is about 20x a
three smart cell genome is about 30X and
a four smart cell genome is about 40x
and we had all this information and we
we wondered what is the actual coverage
we need to get a good de Noble assembly
so this is data from one of our
individuals that we sequenced with four
smart cells we intentionally did this so
that we could look at these kind of
metrics
so on the left hand side of this diagram
what I'm showing you is a fairly basic
plot of what's shown also on the right
hand side
so on the x-axis is the NG value and on
the y-axis are the mega base pairs in
size
so ng50 is sort of easiest to explain
with an example
so mg50 is the value at which 50 of the
contigs in your genome are at the size
that they're at or bigger so for example
for the ng50 for four smart cells you
can see it's
54.4 megabase pairs which means that 50
of that patient's assembled genome is
has contigs of that size or larger
and I hope what you can appreciate as
you look at ng10 which would be the 10
and G50 is 50 and g90 is 90 what I hope
you can appreciate is there's this
really large jump between two smart
cells and three smart cells where our
assembly just gets much better at three
smart cells
now on the right hand side I'm showing
you this across the distribution right
from ng10 all the way to ng100 again you
can see this jump so there's a kind of a
small jump between a one smart cell and
a two smart cell there's a really big
jump between two smart cells and three
smart cells but then moving from three
to four actually doesn't give you that
much better of an assembly
so we thought this is great we kind of
have a a metric of how many smart cells
we want to run and then we started
talking to our colleagues and we talked
to some individuals at Pac bio just
trying to see you know are we kind of in
the right range here and the feedback we
got was you should try Hi-Fi ASM so I
should just point out that I love the
high canoe assembler it's an amazing
assembler
um and I had not tried out Hi-Fi ASM
until um that recommendation so I
thought okay I can do that and I can do
that very formally
so now I'm showing you on the left hand
side the high canoe that I showed you on
the previous slide it's the same plot
it's just got a fixed y-axis so that
they're the same
and what was very surprising to me that
when you look on the right hand side for
HiFi ASM is that the assemblies have
much larger context so it doesn't really
matter which assembler you use one smart
cell is not going to be enough
but having two smart cells with Hi-Fi
ASM was very similar to having three
smart cells with high canoe
so I want to stop for one moment and say
that I'm not saying hi canoe or Hi-Fi
ASM one or the other is better I'm not
saying that but I am saying that this is
a really exciting time because I'm
amazed at where we're at right now in
the field and I think that in the next
few years this is going to get even
better
but we wanted to dig into this just a
little bit deeper so we went back to all
of our pan genome data that we
downloaded um from the web and then all
of our data in-house and we ran high
canoe on all that data and we ran Hi-Fi
Asm on all of that data
and what was really kind of cool and
kind of surprising to me was that with
high canoe there was a really nice
tracking between the ng50 and the
estimated coverage so most of our
samples are European in ancestry and you
can see on the kind of bottom left-hand
side side of the left diagram that
there's a really nice correlation there
and then as you go out to higher depth
what you start to see is that the pan
genome data which is by enlargement
sequence to a larger depth has a sort of
split by populations and that's kind of
intriguing to me um and maybe there's
some kind of genome architecture aspect
to this as well
on the right hand side what you can see
is that the correlation is not as strong
but there are by and large bigger
assemblies right so overall the ng50s
are larger but it's a little bit harder
to predict based on the estimated
coverage what your assembly will look
like
however we do see this kind of split
still by population that we see in high
canoe so I think um this is an
interesting area and uh but for the most
part we could probably say that the
coverage is a pretty important factor
now I wanted to just show you what an
assembly looks like
so this is one individual from our
cohort where we this is their visual
visualization of a high canoe assembly
and a Hi-Fi ASM assembly and that's
pretty much how the data comes back you
have a big file that you have to um of
course a sequence but you go have to go
through and parse and figure out from
the bioinformatics and it's just a
really cool area to be working on at
this moment
so the last part of the talk I was I'm
focusing on this syndrome called Nine P
minus syndrome and in particular
Precision genomics in this syndrome
90 minus syndrome is very rare and in
fact there are many phenotypes seen in
individuals with this syndrome so here
is data we collected from multiple
papers over the years where there has
been an assessment of different
phenotypes and what I'm showing you in
this table are the percentage of
patients that have each phenotype in the
different studies
but I don't really want you to know all
of that information I mean you can look
at it for sure but the main thing I
wanted to point out is that no matter
where the deletion is the individuals
all have developmental delay which is
sort of an intriguing aspect once you
see how the deletions look
now 90 minus syndrome is typified by an
individual having a deletion somewhere
on the P arm of chromosome 9.
we've gone through and aggregated all of
the deletions that we can find from the
literature that have a fairly good
outbreak points based on the traditional
kind of work from karyotype and array so
on the right hand side you can see this
is the P arm of chromosome 9 and
basically all you really need to get
from this are the red bars are the
deletions and the blue ones are the
duplications
so surprisingly some people also have
duplications along with the deletion now
at this point you may be wondering why
is she talking about precision genomics
and long read sequencing for a syndrome
that mostly has a deletion as the main
genetic Factor
well it's because 9p minus syndrome and
about half of the cases is also
accompanied by a more complex event and
it's usually a translocation so this is
from our paper in this past year where
we identified a translocation in a
patient and this is where we had a
duplicated piece of chromosome 13 that
it translocated onto a chromosome 9 that
contained a small deletion
at the time we used 10x genomics to
solve this but we are now using long
read sequencing
and our ultimate goal is to get to
Precision genomics or Precision medicine
or pgpm for 90 minus and what I mean by
that is that we can get precise break
point detection of the structural
variation we can look at the variation
on the allele opposite of the deletion
we can look at assessment of variation
around the genome so a complete genomic
workup because I don't know that we can
ever get to Precision medicine for
genetic syndromes until we can do
precision genomics and that I think is
going to be possible now with long
weight sequencing
so we've I'm showing you here now packed
bio Hi-Fi results from our first 11
individuals with 9p minus syndrome and
here I'm showing you the P arm of
chromosome 9 and where all of those
deletions again you can see that they
are somewhat variable in size and
location just like in the published
literature and you're probably wondering
okay Giselle you said some of the
patients have more Complex events right
and yes they do so here are three of the
individuals
where we have solved the more complex
aspect of their variation
and I'm going to focus on individual one
because it was a challenging case for us
so challenge sorry so individual one
came to us and they had done karyotype
and array and that had solved some of
their variation
so we went about doing this long read
sequencing
and we were trying to figure out the
whole variation in this individual
so now I'm going to just keep that
little schematic on the top left and
I'll put a little box around the areas
I'm looking at as I go so the first
thing that we did when we got back the
long read data was to actually look at
the estimated copy number across 9p
and we did this using the read depth
information and what you can see is that
there appears to be a large deletion a
mosaic duplication and then the rest of
nine is diploid
okay that's great it's really cool
however we knew from the karyotype that
9 should be connected to 14 because
there's a translocation and you can see
it in the karyotype
uh but we couldn't find the break point
and so this was quite challenging for us
so we thought we really got to look into
this further so we zoomed over near the
telomere and looked at this little Spike
that you can see in the data
when we did that to our great surprise
we saw there was actually a small
deletion that's near the telomere
then there's a small diploid segment
right after that and then there's the
beginning of that large deletion
and so we were very curious what where
is this you know piece that's in copy
number of two and we can't figure out
where it connects so what did we do we
did De novo assembly which is so cool
that you can do it with long read data
and when we did that we were able to
query the assembly and find that this
piece of nine had moved to the X
chromosome so this present this piece is
present somewhere else in the genome and
that's why it's retained its status as
being quote unquote diploid
this was incredible to us and it allowed
us to finally figure out the whole Suite
of variation so now at this point
Precision genomics in 9p minus syndrome
is possible and that's just what we're
gonna do it's very awesome
okay so in conclusion
Long Beach sequencing is providing this
all-in-one approach for pgpm and what
we've learned so far in these early days
is that reference base and
assembly-based approaches are both
important
having a lot of control data in public
databases to do frequency filtering is
important we have Nomad we have these
kind of databases for short read data we
need them now for longweek data and I'm
very excited that that will be an
upcoming thing I I hope for our field
the other aspect that I found really
critical was that we can actually phase
genomic variation in most of the genomes
so it's really comprehensive assay
for 90 minus syndrome we want to do pgpm
for this as I mentioned precise break
point detection looking at variation on
the other allele and variation around
the rest of the genome
finally we're now starting to apply pgpm
for insights into autism so recently we
got a smart Grant from Pac bio and we're
focusing on this family and this family
has two girls who have autism an
unaffected boy
now this family is incredibly rare
because autism mostly affects boys and
so
um we were very intrigued and we wanted
to find out why they may have autism in
looking at the genetics and they have
gone on a diagnostic Odyssey not having
any answers from previous genomic
Technologies so with our new Grant what
we've done is packed bio Hi-Fi
sequencing bio Nano genome Imaging and
10x genomics and we're just starting to
go through that data now and I hope that
we'll have some answers in the very near
future
so I will stop there and just thank you
for attending my talk today and I hope
you enjoy the rest of the week thanks